before we move on I want to clarify
something that I've inadvertently done I
think I was not exact with some of the
terminology I use so I want to make a I
want to highlight the difference between
two things that I've used almost
interchangeably up to this point but now
that we are about to embark on learning
what voltage is I think it's important
that I highlight the difference because
initially this can be very confusing I
remember when I first learned this I
found I often mixed up these words and
and didn't quite understand why you know
there was a difference so the two words
are electrical or sometimes you'll see
electric instead of electrical so
electric potential energy and electric
potential I think even in the last video
I used these almost interchangeably and
I shouldn't have I really should have
always used electrical or electric
potential energy and what's the
difference
electrical potential energy is
associated with a with a a charge it's
associated with a you know with out with
a particle that has some charge only
only that particle can have energy
electrical potential or electric
potential this is associated with a
position so for example if I have a
charge and I know that if it's at some
point with a given electric potential I
can figure out the electric potential
energy at that point by just multiplying
actually this value by the charge let me
give you some examples let's say that I
have an infinite infinite uniformly
charged plate so that we don't have to
do calculus we can have a uniform
electric field let's say that this is
the plate let's say I'll make it
vertical just so we get a little bit of
change of pace and let's say it's
positively charged positively charged
plate and let's say that the electric
field you know it's constant right it's
constant no matter what point we pick
these should these field lines should
all these field vectors should all be
the same length because the electric
field does not change in magnitude it's
pushing out because we assume when we
look at when we draw a few lines that we
using a test charge with a positive
charge that's pushing outward so if I
wanted to ask you let's say I have a a 1
Coulomb charge actually make it to
glooms just to hit a point home say I
have a 2 Coulomb charge right here 2
coulombs and it's positive positive two
coulombs arge
and it starts off I don't know let's say
it starts off at 3 meters away and I
want to bring it in 2 meters I want to
bring it in 2 meters so it's 1 meter
away so what is the electric or
electrical potential energy difference
between the particle at this point and
at this point well the electrical
potential energy difference is the
amount of work we now as we've learned
in the previous two videos is the amount
of work we need to apply to this
particle to take it from here to here so
how much work do we have to apply well
we have to apply a force we have to
apply a force that directly that exactly
lets you know we assume that maybe this
is already moving the constant velocity
or maybe we have to start with a
slightly higher force just to get it
moving we have to apply force it's
exactly opposite the electric the the
force provided by this by Coulomb's law
right the electrostatic force and so
what is that that force we're going to
have to apply well we actually have to
know what the electric field is which I
have not told you yet I just realize as
you can tell right so let's say all of
these electric field lines I don't know
let's say they are three Newton's per
Coulomb so at any point what is the
force being exerted from this field onto
this particle well the force from the
electrostatic force on this particle is
equal to the electric field times the
charge times the charge which is equal
to I just defined the electric field as
being three Newton's per Coulomb sorry 3
Newton's per Coulomb times 2 coulombs it
equals 6 Newtons
so at any point the electric field is
pushing this way six Newton's so in
order to push the particle this way
after completely offset that admit and
actually I've get it moving initially
I'll keep saying that I just want to
make that point at that point home so I
have to apply a force of six Newtons in
the leftward direction and have to apply
it for two meters to get the point here
so the total work is equal to six
Newton's times two meters which is equal
to twelve Newton meters or twelve joules
so we could say that the electrical
potential energy energy and energy is
always joules the electrical potential
energy difference between this point and
this point is 12 joules or another way
to say it is this and which one has a
higher potential well this one does
right because at this point we're closer
to the thing that's trying to repel it
so if we were to just let go it would
start accelerating in this direction and
have and a lot of that energy would be
converted to kinetic energy by we get to
this point right so we could also say
that the electric potential energy at
this point right here is 12 joules
higher than the electric potential
energy at this point now that's
potential energy what is electric
potential well electric potential tells
us essentially how much work is
necessary per unit of charge right this
was electric potential energy was just
how much total work is needed to move it
from here to here
electric potential says per unit charge
how much work is it does it take to move
any charge per unit charge from here to
here well in our example we just did the
total work to move it from here to here
with 12 joules but how much work what
did it take to move it from there to
there per charge will work per charge is
equal to 12 joules for what what was the
what was the charge that we move those
two coulombs well it equals 6 joules
per coulomb that is the electric
potential the electric potential
difference between this point and this
point so it was the distinction electric
potential energy was associated with a
particle how much energy how much more
energy did the particle have here than
here when we say electric potential
because we essentially divide by the
size of the particle it essentially is
independent of the size of the particle
it actually just depends on our position
so electric potential we're just saying
how much how much more potential
irrespective of the charge we're using
does this position have relative to this
position and this electric potential
that's just another way of saying
voltage voltage and the unit for volt
for voltage is volts so 6 joules per
Coulomb that's the same thing as 6 volts
and so if we think of the if we think of
the the the analogy to to gravitation
you know we said petrova tation
potential energy was MGH right this was
force this was distance right electric
potential is essentially the amount of
gravitation you know if we if we if we
extend the analogy the amount of
gravitational potential energy per mass
right so if we wanted to know if we
wanted a quick no way of knowing what
the potential at what the potential the
gravitational potential is at any point
without having to care about the mass
well we divide by the mass and it would
be the acceleration of gravity time sign
ignore that if it confused you so what
is useful about voltage it sells
regardless of how small or big or
actually positive or negative a charge
is what the difference in potential
energy would be if we're at two
different points so electric potential
we're comparing points in space electric
potential energy we're comparing we're
comparing charges at points in space
hopefully I didn't confuse you in the
next video we'll actually do a couple
problems where we figure out the
electric potential difference or the
voltage difference between two points in
space as opposed to a charge at two
different points
space I will see you in the next video